it used to be hard to keep food from
spoiling in the so time there was a
person called the Iceman he would come
to your house and sell you a big block
of ice you'd keep it in something called
an icebox to preserve the kinds of food
that spoiled quickly but that was a drag
because the ice kept melting it would
drip all over the floor
so somebody thought up another way to
keep food cold it was a gas-powered
system that used ammonia or sulfur
dioxide as a coolant no more lugging
blocks of ice what could be bad about
that the chemicals were not only
poisonous they smelled terrible and
there were leaks but substitute coolant
was badly needed one that would
circulate inside the refrigerator but
would not poison anyone if the
refrigerator leak or posed a danger if
it was sent to the junkyard
something that wouldn't make you sick
wouldn't burn your eyes or attract bugs
or even bother the cat but in all of
nature no such material seemed to exist
so chemists in the United States
invented a class of molecules little
collections of even tinier things called
atoms that had never existed on earth
before they called them
chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs because they
were made up of one or more carbon atoms
and some chlorine and or fluorine atoms
these new molecules were wildly
successful far exceeding the
expectations of their inventors
[Music]
not only did CFCs become the chief
coolant in refrigerators but also in air
conditioners there were so many things
you could do with CFCs people used them
to propel great fluffy mounds of shaving
cream and to protect your hair from wind
and rain it was also the propellant that
made fire extinguishers and spray paint
cans so much fun it was good for foam
insulation industrial solvents and
cleansing agents the most famous brand
name of these chemicals was freon a
trademark of DuPont it was used for
decades and no harm never seemed to come
from it safe as safe could be everyone
figured until in the early 1970s to
atmosphere chemists at the University of
California Irvine were studying Earth's
atmosphere Mario Molina was a Mexican
immigrant a young laser chemist Sherwood
Rowland was a chemical kinetise Asst
someone who studied the motions of
molecules and gases under varying
conditions he was from a small town in
Ohio Molina
wanted to grow as a scientist he was
looking for a project that would take
him as far from his previous research
experience as possible he wondered what
happens to those freon molecules when
they leak out of the air-conditioner
this was a time when the Apollo
astronauts were still making regularly
scheduled trips to the moon and NASA was
contemplating weekly launches of a space
shuttle would all that burning rocket
fuel
pose a danger to the stratosphere that
place where Earth's atmosphere meets the
blackness of space and this is how
science works a lot of the time you set
out to solve one problem you happen on a
completely different unexpected
phenomenon those wonderfully inert
harmless CFCs the magic molecules of
shaving cream and hairspray didn't
simply vanish when we were done with
them they had an afterlife at the edge
of space where they accumulated into
trillions they were silently
congregating high above the earth and
they were up to no good
Malina and Roland were alarmed to
discover that the CFCs had thinned the
protective layer that shielded us from
the sun's harmful ultraviolet radiation
and it was getting worse all the time
when UV light hits a CFC molecule it
strips away the chlorine atoms once that
happens the chlorine atoms start
devouring the precious ozone molecules
it wasn't until our planet developed an
ozone layer about 2 and 1/2 billion
years ago that it was safe for life to
leave the ocean for the land
a single chlorine atom can destroy
100,000 ozone molecules
[Music]
[Music]
you